[Music]
you're not gonna believe this to
Friendship to Friendship France airships
June children
million little things truly about a
group of friends who were rocked by a
loss one of them dies unexpectedly by
suicide how does this happen why did he
do this makes no sense leads them all to
sort of examine their lives and choose
how to live the rest of them we were
more honest with each other before we
were friends to show about picking up
pieces that show about leaning on people
and allowing them to lean on you and how
sometimes you know catharsis can come
from the most unlikely of sources this
is great because you're using a platform
as the largest ADC to open up the dialog
about dealing with cancer and depression
I spent almost 950 hours sitting next to
John and I had no idea that he was
depressed I want men to look at one
another one go it's true we don't talk
and I want people to reach out to one
another and say did you see that show
that's me that's what I feel like every
day I've never been able to describe it
but did you see Rome that's me
if we're saying hey this is okay to talk
about and it's common and we need to
deal with it together then maybe people
will start doing that he lost sight of
the horizon and nosedived and by the
time he realized what was happening it
was too late he couldn't pull up what
does this have to do that's depression I
would say thank God for the filmmakers
that are not afraid to tackle some of
these issues we're just now kind of
slowly getting out of that stigma of
mental illness being something that with
this taboo we can't touch it something
we don't understand
apparently he and hiding behind a fake
smile just like me you know the shame
and judgment that is attached to it
doesn't leave although a lot of people
wanting to seek help we're trying to
talk about it so that we can exhale we
can breathe easy we can talk to one
another that we can just dispel shame
around it
it's like I can't believe this show
really champions people who are willing
to be vulnerable with each other think
that you know the way it's tackled is
with a lot of love and a lot of
consideration for all parties involved
we are striving to present the most
authentic portrait of middle-aged human
beings dealing with life that we
possibly can
it's a million little million
[Music]